is there a One That Got Away for you
guys
okay this is so weird yeah because
literally I just got over him yesterday
okay like yesterday night I was really
deep in life and then this one was like
you know what okay you said you're 18
you're only 18. yeah okay I've had a lot
of like I've had a lot of experiences
yeah okay but I I think what's your body
count
that's not awesome for today
no no I'm curious so can you answer this
question please he's Kristen what you
just said
I'm not asking on this podcast right now
I mean you you basically said like you
actually said you're a hoe yeah you said
that you said you've been a bad man I
don't think it's going to cause any more
damage
you kind of told everyone anyway
I'm expecting like 20 plus yeah
you want 20 plus
your agent I want to say one thing
though who doesn't just mean to me not
sex please
yeah I'll go into this
fools
no I've had five today
so to clarify yeah so if if if you I
didn't hear that bit but you not said
she refers to herself she's a bit of a
horse or something it was an
introduction
what my point is but should a body count
four so what so any girl that's what so
that is that your kind of guy no but the
girl's got four sex isn't sex isn't what
I mean by who as in like I will talk to
Batman I won't figure what I'm saying
like from my age range if I that makes
you at home as you get older there's
different categories but oh no no that's
not flirting that's just practicing to
be a whole that's a chain you know you
think so you keep getting getting the
man I mean so you understand no man's
mind work so you don't want to twist
them up and do your thing with this and
that that No One's Gonna know like come
on check to a beggar man that's still a
form of cheating big dog no matter how
you look it how is it cheating if you're
single no for real single a real single
so so I see this leading on Wednesday
yeah because I never sometimes yeah like
for example the other day boys started
telling me send me some long paragraph
about how he likes me this and that I
heard it and I was like oh why and I
just like I kept airing the question and
then the other day I was like I can't I
can't do this I don't like you and he's
like yeah yeah but like how did I leave
you on because I never specifically said
I liked you I never backed up in the way
guys look at it if you're like talking
to them on a regular basis it's like
yeah it's like I never confirmed it you
may not have confirmed it but it's still
you're you're taking it and you're young
so this is kind of like when I was
younger I didn't really understand this
either but like men and women can't be
friends they're not your friends the
only reason they're talking they're
they're trying they're trying no okay
yeah and I promise you and I promise you
I promise you I promise you if you were
300 pounds they would not be your friend
I'm telling you I have got genuine
boyfriends that think about me that I've
been friends
can I just give this girl a bit of
advice in future like don't introduce
yourself as a whole
I just going forward yeah moving forward
introduce yourself just just put you in
it no but it wasn't it I think I'm
trying to explain something I can't get
it what's wrong you see you see this is
what I say to the man them yeah if
you're attract work young and you don't
get a [ __ ] you know we tell her to [ __ ]
off
[Music]
so if you like someone so much and she
don't [ __ ] you after the eighth day
I said A week
I'll explain this to you like from the
guy's point of view like most girls from
the guy's point of view it's like most
girls there's someone you've let sleep
with you you quickly at some point in
your life what about the guys okay okay
let's let's not the point that's not the
point at some point let's wait wait okay
you got it you gotta wait at some point
in your life most girls have let someone
sleep with them quickly so from the
guy's point of view if if you're not if
you're making him wait a long time
you're just not that guy and and I do
interviews all the time with girls on
the street and like they'll like I had a
girl the other day she said she told me
if I'm at Bruno Mars tomorrow it would
be on it would be because that's the one
I think because of his Fame but I feel
like for me I've recently started
talking to this guy right and we've been
talking and I feel like I'm not ready to
give him the problem yet because I want
to keep him on his selfish do you like
him do you like him see that's why
that's why let me tell you something I
mean
but let me tell you something from a
man's point of view yeah
like you could be in a situation yeah
where you've met a girl and
she don't know about
my brother here I don't know him off
camera but he might have done something
over there yeah but he might I just she
might not have liked him so she just cut
through her prerogative in it she just
wanted to beat so she just beat in it
I've come along now yeah she's thinking
raw
she likes it like she likes man she
wants to she don't want to come across
in a certain way to man so now she got
along at the Pom-Pom she's lying to you
so what I'm saying for my man's point of
view is like hold on a minute you're
taking man for Egypt that's how man
looks like no he's not looking at me
like that no but I'm saying in that
situation a man would look for a
girlfriend last week no but I just
wanted to [ __ ] you no but I'm not saying
you're wrong not from a man you're using
sex you're using you're using sex as a
weapon to get committed him on the first
night I feel like instantly he'll be
like you know what I've had them
coming across his wife
and that's and that and that's and
that's fair if you are Wi-Fi
let me stop stop if that's fair if you
are wifey and if you have never done
that but most men like they can kind of
get a vibe from a girl and they're like
you know what she's probably done that
at a certain age she's probably done
that with someone for free so why why am
I I have a [ __ ] for money yeah I can say
that I've done it for free whatever I've
done you you know what I'm saying though
like at some point at some point she has
she has done that for a guy that hasn't
taken her on a date
stop interrupting me you've done it like
four times if you do it again you can't
stay on okay so at some point she has
done it for free at some point she has
done it for a guy that She chased or
that that she didn't have to take that
he didn't have to take her on a date and
so you're gonna have the next guy do all
of this because of your past trauma yeah
but no I wouldn't I wouldn't just like
see a guy just because he's gonna take
me on a date XYZ not every guy that I
have seen I've been like oh let me make
him wait X Y and Z because I like
how old are you how old are you I'm 23.
okay at some point has there been a guy
that you haven't made weight that long
well I was previously an eight year
relationship and I've got a child and
I've left here but have you had the one
that's done I've met I've met a guy once
yeah and then I've spoke to him on
social media and met him ended up
sleeping with him and realizing he
wasn't the one so it has happened so
that's right yeah which is which is fine
I'm not I'm not saying like that you do
that often but I'm saying if you've done
that once for someone the guys see that
as disrespectful because you're gonna
make this the next guy get to know you
and do all this stuff when you gave it
to the last guy
sometimes I feel like sometimes when you
have it I feel like there's levels
levels to it so if there's someone that
you genuine like there's some some guys
out here and be like you know what babes
I just want to [ __ ] I don't want a
relationship I don't want to settle down
I just want to [ __ ] and that's up to the
woman if she feels like she wants stuff
up too but I feel like it's different
aspects if you're actually wanting to
get to know that person and and build a
foundation with that person but that's
what a woman's point of view right and
who is here to judge me if that's no but
I didn't say yeah no but I'm saying in
general from my man's point of view like
that's why I said it's your prerogative
I'm just saying from a man's perspective
yeah this is how in general like men
look on things you say I'm gonna say let
me flip it on his head down here from a
woman's perspective now yeah say like
you're dating a man that puts his
business on social media in terms of
when he's seeing a girl you know about
his life it's on it's what I'm saying
they'll go on dates he'll post it if
he's buying up things he'll post it and
he's that type of guy where he's taking
an uptown regular he buys a little gifts
regular he posts it regular you've seen
that previously yeah him and the girl's
done now yeah you and him start talking
now so boom now you've like so imagine
now he just wants to come and chill out
your yard he's not on no I'm telling you
now majority of girls will have an issue
that could not be saying hold on a
minute I've seen you taking kaisha
Uptown
what's going on like but hold on you
just want to come around and watch
Netflix and chill and Boom Beach we beat
that hold on dead that's what I'm trying
to say so with a man it's the same thing
if a man knows a girl has like
previously and I'm not saying there's
nothing wrong with it for a man's
perspective as previously except with X
Y instead maybe not on the first night
but you know I mean like pretty soon
first night second night whatever and
then with him she's trying to do like
the get to know I'm not saying there's a
problem with that because from her
perspective it's from the writer that
she's thinking now I want to settle down
but from his perspective you're taking
him a big dog you know what you just say
it's so cool I mentioned a few things
and I always got this thing you know
I've done this in the past I'm not doing
it again fam why are you gonna tell me
that you was home with me are you a map
listen Jesus
I've done that bro I mean all of it if
you told me that you [ __ ] two [ __ ]
before you better believe I'm not gonna
ask you to [ __ ] a chick with me I want
all of that [ __ ] but are these women
saying it just off the gospel are you
asking them the questions
let me ask you yeah yeah so you got you
ain't got a man knowing it no I'm saying
are you [ __ ]
like
I swear I swear so cool see it's so cool
so are you chatting to a man now uh no
no no no no man you're like you know
like I'll reply to like the hey
beautiful and yeah
so that's Europe so man complimenting
that's your thing because you're alone
you said I remember like what's up my
princess is that what gets you going no
hey man them yeah
that's the same crusty line that you use
on all women nah nah I'm a stink back
I'm the most honest I'm gonna tell you I
wanna [ __ ] oh okay it's up to you what
you want to do and how does that work
out for you it works I'm a funny [ __ ]
okay funny get [ __ ]
I make people laugh yeah you know what
I'm saying yeah but in general them
sweet nothings are what women want to
hear in general they don't they don't
want to hear the truth they say they do
but in general if his approach in
general would not work honestly the man
that say in the sweet nothings to her
you're beautiful and all that in general
that would work no but I'm say it in
general like women would say they want
what you're saying blunt honesty like yo
I just want to bend you over right now
but hear what I'm saying majority of
time you're sexy you know it depends
what night it is
but you know what it is
going up what you said yeah you know the
majority of girls yeah yeah would think
what you just said in their head don't
be touched but you see their response
will be different to what they think
yeah but if the Hennessy is involved
anyway but maybe because everybody
it's kind of like it's kind of like um
okay imagine if you bought a purse right
and you've spent 500 on a purse
and you three you bought Sam Pairs and I
I came in and I said I got the same
purse for 150. gasp would you be kind of
salty yeah I would but sex is not sex is
not the same thing as me yeah it is
let's flip it let's flip it okay as a
woman
um imagine
oh okay you found out you're dating a
guy and you found out like like he
bought you let's say a hundred dollars
something for your birthday and you find
out his ex-girlfriend he rented out a
whole club threw her a whole party
invited all of her friends
and at first and at first right you you
would be excited for the hundred dollar
gift and you would think oh wow this
this guy's so nice until until
you find out about his ex that he did
all of that that's the equivalent for
guys
to add on to that yeah because I
mentioned something similar when I said
like you've seen a guy dating experience
online and he's doing all the Uptown
stuff then with you he just wants to
Netflix and chill at your house like
you're gonna think huh and even to to go
for that point you can take it with with
it's a it's another reason why men not
like a girl that's very active like
dating wise and sexually wise because if
you're active dating wise you're gonna
have more there's more charts of you
having those experiences where you're
getting the the big money purses and
whatnot and what not and it's just
natural that when the next man comes
along now you might not have that but if
a man wants to do that he would do that
no but he might not have that okay he
might not have it then that's fine and
then but but it's it's not always
fighting for the majority of women
because now you're thinking hold on a
minute I've been used to my last
birthday no but you can have your own
but on your last birthday your man took
you X Y and Z this birthday a man's
buying a Chinese saying yo that's true
one more for men it's like you've had a
girl yeah that is doing the most in the
bedroom like doing the most like because
you're sexually active bro then you've
got a next thing good girl and that you
like her but in the bedroom she can't
really Arch her back and then things
if a girl puts out on the first date you
wife in it yeah if the push is good what
was my problem yeah I wouldn't say no I
wouldn't say no but for me that's a red
flag cause you imagine what if she only
slept with you on the first date there
you go what if it was you no I was the
only person yeah first time I wouldn't
believe it I wouldn't believe it no I
understand that I like it as well you
know all the time we get into things
about the bodycon watch your body come
big dog
[Music]
one of them you know why because I can
see what she's been doing man no need
there's not it's all in the Life only
want to lie and you're walking down the
right time because Tom the sneak on your
thumb on the night before
yeah
right in all seriousness right and this
is a serious Auntie Jenny coming on now
right because you are talking so much
rubbish earlier that when they talk
about body care I I just zoned that up
the fact that I don't want to hear what
he's not got to say but that's why I
asked the question again
four at 18 there's nothing to be proud
about right I'm telling you now I know
because when I heard the 15 before 30
that's where it starts from so as far as
I'm concerned you see your four
keep it at 40 you're 30. no no no no no
no keep it at four don't be going out
and I'll date some winding up the guys
don't be going out and saying oh I'm
gonna go to you just in case right
because if I was a man and I took you
out and you're not feeling it I'm gonna
feel offended especially if you're not
going to go out for a date to look for
forward to having a relationship so you
see your four I want to hear from you
that in five years time it's still full
unless you got a ring on your finger in
10 years time that is still four unless
you got your finger and your ring on
your finger right and take don't shut up
take advice
from an older woman that four but 18 is
nothing to be talking about right you
need no stop I'm talking to a young lady
I'm trying to teach her for all you men
out there that wanna [ __ ] her stop do
not have anymore I'm seriously I'm not
you but men in general I'm telling you
I'm serious now 18.
when you think about the legal age is
16.
please don't don't do it don't do it to
yourself I'm telling you right because
I'm trying to save you from yourself
don't listen to anybody else that send
you it's okay tell them that Auntie
Jenny says I've got to shut it down from
now on I tell you what you do right DM
me when you want to have sex again and I
will meet you wherever you are man I
will drive 200 and whatever miles and
stop you from having sex anytime you
feel frisky you find that you're in a
relationship with a man call me and I
will come down there and I will [ __ ]
blocks
I'm telling you because as if he was my
daughter you'd be coming home with me
now if you're living on your own I'll be
taking you home because four are
eighteen it's disgusting it's disgusting
don't listen to them that other women
anything that is good if you want to
date tell them that Auntie Jenny says
I'm gonna shut my legs when I'm on a
date if you wanna date with me just talk
to me but don't have no more sex because
the people out there and the women that
are teaching you that it's okay they're
telling you rubbish they're lying to you
you know what because they're jealous of
your youth so the only thing you got now
is your Youth and your low body count so
don't let no older woman tell you no
different keep your body cat Low by
shutting your legs concentrate on your
career from now on because when I heard
four I thought myself it could possibly
be you because when I was like oh 25 I
was on four and you're 18 on four it's
not good don't do it don't listen to
nobody and I'm telling you the truth or
if I can drive 135 miles to have sex
with my man I will drive 200 miles to
[ __ ] block you
that's so funny because that's what I
wanted to say because I couldn't believe
that the four I had to check four and
check your age again that's why I've
been waiting it all quiet because I
couldn't believe that 18 year old I had
my son at your age
and that's where it stopped do you mean
one and my son at your age and you're
having four you're gonna children stop
before you get pregnant and it stops you
don't have nothing Auntie Jenny why are
you being like this though no I agree
with you
hey no I know you're trying to shake it
off
she's like a daughter to me my son's 37.
that could be my grandchild right now
listen I can't block him I know anywhere
you see her right any man wants to have
sex with this woman remember Auntie
Jenny be after you I've got you Mark I
do not have sex in this young woman
because she belongs to me
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible